um
thanks for coming what an honor
information
so encouraging I mean in so many ways to
see just the remarkably stoic nature of
the people of Ukraine and of course
your messaging that I think is reflected
in their courage and in their
determination and in their perseverance
and resilience is just
it's uh you know it's it's to see the
children to see in their eyes
um it's palpable the anxiety and yet the
strength of the Ukrainian people is
something that is
really awe-inspiring in truth so it's uh
and of course you know your messaging is
the reason for that so it's remarkable
to see how you are you know holding this
country and uh and we all we have a good
country well we hold each other